hey come on in Brad Paisley how's it
going guys hi man how you doing the
young legend Brad Paisley how are you is
that a good title because I feel like I
think legend is it doesn't legend get
rid of implies you're done right about
to die right and you got a lot left in
the tank I hope but the young legend is
like okay right I don't know what do you
like I dream big you're not supposed to
like if someone calls you 11 you're like
oh no but you gotta like you want to be
legends a legend is sort of like you
know yeah it's like body of work right
yeah you had a great run
Oh like yes there is an end of the spot
that's the legends like reunion tour
right right legend kind of state that
you're almost at the end as opposed to
still young with a lot of stuff would
think so Garth Brooks is a legend well
yeah but I don't
yeah right choice boy a legend because
he's accomplished so much all right
I feel like he's also not he's not
anywhere near done but at the same time
you know it's more fun to think of
myself as young yeah if you're
gray-haired you could be legend yeah I
got something if you're gonna games if
you're great you're young legend young
legend a legend a young make it out of
that young legends I look back to man
come on
no all right I'll take it I guess how do
you do with that there's certainly worse
things on the internet right now
absolutely we're called all of them is
success something that like you strive
forward or did you just want to be a
musician because the the level of
success that you've achieved through
your music is like unbelievable like 12
million albums sold ten or something
gold albums like it did
I feel like crazy I feel like a you know
success is the type of thing that I
honestly it sounds like I'm like this is
can but it's really true I it's it's all
about you know am I happy with the music
I'm making and the fact that I've been
able to make a good living and play for
audiences with this music that I like to
do I'm pretty happy because nobody ever
made maybe something I didn't want to be
right what's the difference in country
music now and like older country music
like it's like more appealing to like
young people now because I never
listened to it like Johnny Cash is kind
of like the the person who's a novice
listens to music
yeah and Johnny Cash is that's as good
as it gets I mean it's you know it is
what it is Johnny Cash doesn't sound
like other people at Johnny Cash
you know that he wasn't necessarily
typical of the era he was in that's
maybe why he's one of the greatest of
all time is that the johnny was like you
know it's Johnny it sounded like Johnny
yeah like a Michael Jackson song is
always a Michael Jackson song yeah man I
wrote that about like the weekend
doesn't Alien Ant Farm to do the job
killed it they said nice job with yes
both criminal but you know the old
country music was I I like to think of
it as different it was different topics
I mean you know they talked about trains
in prison and and some things like that
and we don't necessarily do that but but
you know we've evolved in terms of the
stuff that we talk about although we've
regressed lately what about a female
country I can't get into it
you're too violently like Clinton what
are you blind I took too bad I can look
at them beautiful later they kill guys
al it's too violent Peter are you
insecure with the female empowerment its
I'm insecure with females murdering oh
what's this all about the girls all
right the guys car everyone it carried
us Carrie Underwood right yeah that's
our song they're poisoning before he did
we should give it though do will we did
yes oh you're feeling into the gravity
of email country stars they got you
bullied there could be a primary over
here baby I'm fight back for that dog
sitting over here fight back against
these spiteful vengeful actually did one
on a couple albums ago that was like the
the male version of that where it was a
song called karate I really love the
song I had Charlie Daniels actually rap
in it that's awesome because he was like
Charlie was like the original rapper
nobody thinks about that but think about
Devil Went Down to Georgia
there was no rap yet yeah and it was
blondie got big credit for a rap I guess
Pajar Lee Daniels did do that song
before rapture right
I don't know but it's around that time
but he didn't know that he was doing rap
but you know rap was appropriated from
country music that's right in that sense
yeah when you do it like hot takes red
tape Brad Wow kandi yeah let's let it
send it to TMZ there are no definitive
statements that always work but I feel
like in this case with with the song
that I was doing I had a good time a
song called karate and what it is is
it's about this this woman that's in an
abusive relationship and the whole song
she's training to basically like kick
his ass so I could Jhelum
yeah it's a little like that he's
exactly like that and then by the end
it's like basically she comes home and
he's been drinking again and it's all
that the chorus is uh about you know he
he's in a bar chasing Cuervo with Tecate
he doesn't know she's been taking karate
I had to find a lick of something that
rhymed with karate I got excited and
then because it's a pretty redneck beer
too it's very difficult to do the
reverse though like what's the the men
get in there and eat your annoying wife
well that's all I don't think the only
one that I did those by the way in the
60s I think the difference now we're
coming back away with it what do you
mean heat with he had a song where mom
and mom is in the graveyard pop is in
the pen
no no that's in the graveyard you got it
backwards I did oh yeah the guy died
listen sometimes you switch it up for a
living I Drive his truck into the motel
oh you're right yeah Bethenny you're a
big fan right yeah no he's like the
hottest an area here do don't we yeah
but that's I mean I'll go ahead you had
the truckstop shirt you had the you know
I think and the flames on it absolutely
absolutely I like my song Garth Brooks
did he did a cover of hard luck woman my
chest you hear that song again he he
would nail stuff like that when he
covered Billy Joel it was good too used
to do he may be right do you cover any
rock I love like that is my favorite
[ __ ] that Johnny Cash did was like Rick
Rubin when he covered all those uh like
Danzig and all those oh yeah I got his
nails I'll do whatever I can get away
with it that fits my voice like I always
I love to do Layla the acoustic version
of that that's my favorite rock song a
lot of times it is but you know the yeah
just to flat-out 70s rock record on
Layla to me is you know just never been
anything cooler as far as a guitar lick
or even what it's about and then but I
love the the MTV Unplugged version he
did so I'll cover claps then sometimes
yes claps you got me on my knees Lilia
yeah and you probably be promoting a
comedy tour so I guess you always been a
comedy fan and you're down for Nashville
and you had gone to that Wild West
Festival yeah well I hosted a night for
the last three years and where I would
write specifically songs and some bits
you know and love stand-up comedy world
and started getting into that and
getting to know a few these guys that
are part of the special
and you know in for a long time when I
first started as a kid I was singing and
I was from a little town of 1,200 people
and so I was booked solid I was you know
it was the Lions Club luncheon and then
he you know the mother-daughter banquet
at the local Baptist Church I was you
know I was able to get $50 a night
anytime I wanted but I learned early on
that it's like okay you can sing these
songs but it's what's happening between
the songs it's really sort of where
people will judge whether or not they
had a good time because there's nothing
worse to me than going to see a
performer where nothing happens between
songs like that we just saw turns in
roses and they were great and I was like
I wish actually talked to the crowd a
little bit more yes amazing is the show
was he didn't talk to the crowd at all I
kind of went one day and not really no I
kind of like when there's a little
interaction absolutely yeah especially
on acoustic nights like if there's a if
there's a night where there's you know
and so I learned quickly some some of
those little things in your bag of
tricks that that always work that you
know ways to to do that and so this is
an expansion of that trying to do
stand-up and and and also hosting the
CMA Awards every year like Carrie and I
have done you know we write that and we
we work on we've worked on our stick
Carrie Underwood yeah
or you feel that she would be violent at
any point of time oh definitely give me
such a violent way mournful then where's
the Christianity well when I think
forgiving us I think that it says in the
Bible that you can kill a man when a
woman killed America I do remember that
part as well do you get laughs on stage
when you're in between songs yeah I try
do you know I've watched I love Elvis
and Elvis is the only icon who has ever
bombed in front of his own crowd Elvis
would tell jokes and they would never
get laughs he used to say I guess he's
on pills eating it was [ __ ] it was just
fun to watch Elvis through you know
battling out jokes and then all the day
was just getting nothing from the
audience it was so great to watch this
guy bombing in front of his own crowd I
will I will roast my audience and
they've gotta know me enough that I can
get away with it like you know how it's
like there's a lot of sort of pandering
to your audience yeah in rock or country
music because you know you stand up
there and it's like this is you know
this is the greatest city and I'll stand
up and I'll go
what do you people live here in the
middle of the concert you know
Minneapolis it's like yeah many apples
it's great to be or no it's not it's
winter what the hell are we doing here
is there you know is there something
about like comedy where when you do
something as well as you've done country
music I'd say you've mastered country
music not that you're finished there's
that but wow you done heaps going back
to finish done very very well so I get
you out the paint bro yeah
come you but you look at like a comedian
and go like that's that's something I'd
like to really master as well yo yeah
again I mean yeah I'm a student of it
I've watched many a stand-up special and
and sort of studied why you know how you
get this thread through sort of an
evening you know those things where you
sort of seamlessly weave into stuff and
it's easy for me when I write a couple
songs I can do that
you know I'll write something that's
kind of you know that's it's a bit it's
actually like there are songs as writers
in Nashville where we write things all
the time but don't make the record and
that's all this is a stand-up special
sort of me saying oh this is a venue
where I can play that song about dating
your cousin that we wrote that I that I
would never put on a record but boy it
kills when I sing it so I know and it's
kind of fun to do that but the hard part
like we were saying is in between songs
it's like how do you weave them together
and do a cohesive bit and then only just
promote Brad it's called Brad Paisley's
comedy rodeo it's a one-hour special
available now on Netflix oh I'm sorry
Tuesday August 15 sorry and it's got
Mikey Winfield who I don't know David
Hasselhoff Mike's amazing is he a good
comments he's amazing I know John have
Franz a buddy of mine I know Nate
bargatze is really funny if I got teased
really Jon REEP and Sarah Tiana and so
you hire is really funny too
I don't know Sarah and John is uh John's
really funny John's whole the bit that
John does and this special is all about
how he finds his dad's porno tape and
it's it's an amazing sort of in what's
crazy is it's kind of PG yeah things PG
his thing and and yet he's talking about
finding that tape and what happened and
it's true have you ever have you ever
done because I John Mayer I love Johnny
cuz Johnny goes on and John likes to be
funny yes you got out of the Comedy
Cellar sometimes and he'd go on and just
do pure comedy sets yeah
Vanda on did you ever want to do like a
pure set where you just go up there and
just talking I don't know well you have
I've done a lot yeah how'd it go it went
great I actually have done Kevin Nealon
is one of my best friends and and I'll
go sit in with him at the Laugh Factory
I've done that before where we'll go out
he does a new material night which is
fantastic which is like you know I love
that we're you know then I that that I
did it
Jeselnik was there and he had you know
it's just people holding your they're
holding cucumbers and their best that we
have a new joke night at the cellar I
put it yet they do money if there's it's
my favorite show how many bomb how many
like how many to the jokes yeah if your
jokes aren't bomb you're [ __ ] up yeah
right right
when I think we're doing their old stuff
I'm like what are you wasting when you
was out of that last from $10 jack a
mysterious snowy but really exactly and
I love that tightrope of all of that I
love it
the worst is when you're bombing like we
we can we get out of a good bomb but the
worse is when you're bombing and you're
like okay I'm bombing now let me pull
out yeah you can't
that's the worst when you think like
this stuff the tricks that normally get
you out of it when they don't and you're
like oh my god I'm like legitimately
they're bombing there's a moment in this
special that's my favorite moment of the
whole thing which is a hundred percent
just I am I am about to bomb because I
out of the blue decide I didn't prepare
it but I had written a song for my
wedding my wife wanted a song and I was
like I've written you ten songs that's
why you're married right
she's like no I want one for our wedding
I want one that you just wrote for this
and I'm like that's not fair you know
little moments was like number two on
the chart you know you wrote that was to
win me over I want one now you know and
so I like had this assignment and so I
wrote a song that's the cousin [ __ ]
one that's no that's later that was pure
fantasy through this is all it's called
toilet-seat song and because we went to
some two-bit hack counselor that that
her entire like problem that she felt
like premarital counseling her entire
problem was that i don't put toilet seat
down that was the main main issue we
were going to have in our marriage
got a great solution for that oh I
should put it up no I just say
transwomen so it doesn't matter
I saw you read in there thank you doing
boy oh you yeah your life and I have a
second day you just send me an even
bolder thing that's absolutely amazing
that that somebody's job you've paid a
person sure to let you know you know
this could be an issue keep leaving the
toilets you know and just like her I
don't know why they want us to leave the
toilet seat down that just gets it peed
on more yeah trust me on him yeah but
basically with the special eye I pulled
that out of my butt I was like oh you
know what I'm gonna play this one
because you never know it might make the
special and I said I talked about this
and why I wrote this song and I'm about
to sing it but see I I had actually been
doing this for 10 years
this song ever you know and I started to
sing it and I can't remember the opening
line or the second line and so luckily
there are a lot of my fans in the
audience and I was like do you got does
anybody have the lyric on this and they
did like somebody there's it we left all
that in there like it's me
going through the audience getting a
phone reading it off the phone as I'm
doing the song and it works it's my
great whole special yeah because for a
comedian is you don't remember the joke
and firstly I've never seen a singer not
remember a song before I would love to
watch someone to go to you fumbling to
get delirious that we that everyone on a
show that's worth your $10 nozzles I
don't remember any of his lyrics when he
raps is hilarious I love that Ozzy would
always sing because he was dyslexic so
he would always sing the verses in
Reverse you would always sing the lines
in reverse and or he would [ __ ] up and
sing the same one twice I loved it I
loved when a live show comes upon a
living and the crazy rails yeah yeah
just a little bit of a falling apart
making a live show that's why people
like stand-up because like that you
don't know what's going to happen yeah
yeah and that's right someone heckles
yeah everybody shuts up to listen to
your response oh yeah cloud work or they
agree I love that have you been heckled
oh yeah in concert the main heckle that
happens in concert like last night there
was a girl who just and you know I
pretended not here because you got the
ear monitor yeah I don't we're playing
really loud but she was louder and she
just kept yelling she just kept like
getting closer and moving up to the
front front row and just yelling just
yelling it's my birthday over
over again and I swear she did that for
two hours last night every single song
that's my birds like what do you want
acknowledge it at all it was easier not
to because I didn't know I could tell
she was with two the one that it would
not end if I - they have been nowhere a
little bit of gravy went did anybody
have any birthdays did she scream went
alright no one gave me a bit play
another song but to stand there and
screaming alive perform it's so crazy
dude
have you got nasty hackles oh yeah like
that that was a nice heckle and those
are harder because a nice hacker is like
somebody's trying to have fun with you
yeah ought to be nice yeah you can't
[ __ ] on them because they actually
really love you you don't know what
they're doing is wrong those are the
word you're my favorite as I kind of
love thank you what about what's the
worst thing anybody said do they try to
roast you not we you know that's the
beauty of being a musician typically
you're pretty loud yeah and I mean for
the most part it's sort of like they
it's more like you know mad that you
didn't sing what they wanted you know
writing like sing it was fun in Sweden
the other day because we just toured
there and they're a different audience
they don't know which songs were hits so
all the way back to my first album which
is 17 years ago now I mean we're talking
about their they they know the words to
everything yeah there's no like line
there and and they there was somebody
holding up a note that's our big thing
that said play cloud of dust that's like
track seven first album it's about a
drought in Texas has nothing to do with
Sweden not only that but I haven't sung
it since like 1999 did you remember the
words if you had to or no no way I'm
like and they're like and they were
really great people you could see and
they had waited forever and they're
wanting to hear cloud of dust and I'm
like I would do that for you if I knew
the first word of it and I don't even
know any of it I know the hook is cloud
of dust yeah and so the next night they
wrote them out on post one the why did
you sing it yeah I use our board yeah I
use cue cards and this sets an amazing
does your voice go at all cuz it's the
biggest meanest singer seems like so
much fun but then you guys have to worry
about your voice go so what do you do if
your voice is kind of shut I'm I'm
typically very good no
Cawood about knowing when I'm reaching
that line and shutting up and that's the
thing I haven't ever the only time I
ever had to cancel had to cancel Austin
City Limits once and come back and do it
later because I had lost my voice and
the only other thing I had that weekend
was a private show in Texas for
corporation and they didn't care if I
could sing or not so I basically went
and did that sounded terrible
okay and did you tell them before like
hey look this is not yeah they don't
care you know I mean there's people
eating dinner and you know in suits just
happy that you were there do it again
yeah I was like what's ideal that's what
I think
yeah yeah exactly question okay I grew
up here in New York City a lot of times
you hear people say this sentence now
what's your favorite type of music I
like all types of music except country
yeah I've heard that there's a
prejudicing it residency dance country I
admittedly Harry
tell me that why is about I just found
country by the way who put me on was it
you put no no you guy I'd put you on to
some more stuff yeah yeah but it's
multi-layered it's sort of like a you
know the the twang aspect of it some of
the stuff it doesn't have as much of
that anymore as it used to I mean and
from in my opinion unfortunately but it
it's easier it's more palatable now
because it's sort of more represents it
sounds a little more like 70s rock
honestly or even pop but but I think
that there's a twang aspect that you
just associate that steel guitar and
that twangy guitar thing that rubs
certain New Yorkers their own way maybe
and and I think that but it's an
acquired thing it's like your first sip
of beer is sort of you know typically
kind of like what is this all about it's
also as you start to know the new beers
Rascal Flatts well that's true it's also
associated and probably unfairly so for
a long time people were seeing like well
you're racist like country it's
associated with bad social things even
though there's no connection to the guys
doing it now at all right I probably had
that it's like people say with rap they
think other guys are shooting each other
it's just a weird Association well they
also think that the subject matter isn't
relatable like if you live in New York
City and we're singing about tractors
and that was the thing that I always
wondered too is similar like going where
people love NWA yeah yeah and they
cannot relate to that [ __ ] at all no
we just want to say the name of the
group
but I think like when when you think
about it's the same reason why it worked
for me to sing country music in Sweden
they're not doing they're not been left
4-wheel drives and go mud bogging in
Sweden yeah but and I also don't wear
cowboy hats typically right but when I
come to town and we do something they're
decked out I mean you know it's chaps
and holsters they're like ready they
think yes